hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play dead space 3
okay I had to go through a lot to get
this to work again um apparently when it
first installed the very last portion of
the game was corrupt I didn't know no
hello for you to build up you endlessly
pursue your own destruction for the
tampering move earth gobble
I'll show you yes sorry I can't hear
what if painlessly transcended to our
ultimate end our predestined rebirth
okay and I shoot you in the face oh oh
it's not gonna be you that is shooting
me in said face I am going to be
shooting you in said face okay so
apparently release toxin that doesn't
sound good
um yep nah I thought gotta get out of
here hey we're okay yeah that doesn't
seem good what the hell is that stuff
that it just oh yeah
should probably close the door hahaha
what is that stuff that it just
dissolves everything organic
I mean it's useful seems pretty bad
though I mean if he can even get me
through my suit I don't know I've
actually had to play through a lot of
the game to get back because as I said I
reinstalled my entire game and ergo I
have a lot of supplies that I didn't
have before because I got to go through
everything tonight I'm gonna hit a
couple um optional missions and a lot of
resource bots so don't judge me and now
my fault I was just having fun
don't blame me okay so anyway
Isaac lurked allowed to have fun if
Isaac luck want to have fun okay no okay
all right my circuits are still upgraded
and I played a bit of around with some
more weapons and I couldn't find
anything even compared to this one that
I got so just uh for the time being and
because I'm on hard I'm just gonna stick
with it
good Edie I think there's only one more
piece of oh did I get the Lao ello screw
here buddy
oh thank you Ha Na
countdown to reload by later Gotham II
um [ __ ] you
holy balls oh this is bad this is bad
this is really really bad I shouldn't
have been in this room everyone gets
stunned thank you ah that's it mama got
me I'm trying to how come I can't stasis
anything there we go little bit more
often man this is a bad idea coming in
here why can't I stasis you
reload reload I'm more how did I miss
point-blank with a shotgun
Jesus stop it
go away oh my god
I made a huge mistake coming back into
this little hallway those a bad ah
another one oh stop it stop infinitely
spawning actually I guess you can keep
going because you keep giving me
supplies so oh there it is
hi hello Rosetta case y'all haven't
figured out rosetta ain't exactly human
oh hello
I hear it where is you tango
Thank You Billy go get me some supplies
I have so much tungsten it's not even
funny okay uh oh yeah oh dude good grab
Rosetta that might help me in my project
to get Rosetta
hey yeah yeah either soon be there soon
baby
I can't be awake to be back in your arms
again wait what
oh okay nothing alright moving forward
ha ha lollipop ha good eye
get away Jesus Christ y'all slow down
for a second there bat Cubs the Lord
where were they hiding that's what I
want to know those things ain't exactly
subtle those things are kind of large
and in charge
hey at least I don't have that
regenerating thing after me again okay
moving forward good thing I got so many
med kits I picked up so many med kits on
my way and I forgot to sell them in a
bench so whatever gets thrown at me I'm
kind of ready
hi crap
Danny's gunships are patrolling the area
okay don't even see it it's gonna be bad
if they see me better hurry up that [ __ ]
my bad not Jimmy not doesn't hurt good
thing I got so many med kits ow
actually that didn't hurt much at all
okay they're gonna be pursued me for a
while I no problem I think too badass to
be effective by beauty machine guns oh
hello hello come back here I want to
play please hello
oh I didn't even think I was there I
press the blue okay good enough hi
that's what you get you should have
expelled that's a fast one
Jesus balls slow down there twitchy take
it easy man that guy was double quick I
mean those are the those are the things
from that's based one I don't I don't
remember seeing them in Dead Space 2 is
there another one okay it's like I'm
finally full up go away oh come on how
did that not dismember you
there's a lot of you stays it I missed I
missed again
I gave you my pest Jesus Christ man
those things there's quickest bunnies I
have like no hope of ever hitting them
with with a freaking Kinesis thing and
apparently I am like the worst stasis er
in the history of stasis aghh I like hit
the side of that truck twice maybe I
shouldn't sell all these med kits cuz
I'm gonna be in trouble if these guys
are coming up on me that go oh thank you
hi belly thank you for getting me some
goodies I'll sell a few oh look at all
those delicious resources uh God so many
resolve a tug stud ah okay let's see I
need actually I need another torque bar
but I do not need as many med kits as I
have no cells up not that I need the
materials anyway Salim yeah that'll do
does that do
dad I'll do okay we're good for now
damn I am I fully upgraded I need to see
that and seven suit oh well that's about
time I played Mass Effect for a while I
was wondering why I didn't get that C
duration okay I did a few other ones
here before as I was making my way cuz I
had so many materials so I am almost
nearly fully upgraded oh man that's
gonna suck up my transducers I hardly
use Kinesis anyway there's pish-posh
fish VOSH drish gosh where am I going
this way I'm all done that's right I
need to go on a mission no no thank you
I don't need to what's specifically so
co-op about it I don't have any friends
duh Isaac Clark don't need no friends
why did Clark it on Isaac Clark is an
Isaac Clark he's a badass I like going
I'm going back to the lab or something
is this back to the lab I remember where
the lab is
oh yeah this is decontamination hello
baby
how you doing did you miss me figure
this thing out before getting finds us
something like bones connected well you
know whatever the hell that is
hey hey you're so funny Carver okay
Ellie you're not even gonna say hi to me
huh
writing all over the walls Ellie's just
gonna boot buttons up there sorry didn't
mean to point my gun at you okay I need
to reassemble this um that looks like
the head let's look at the
cross-sections um uh hell that yeah
that's right this one here this one's
ooh okay so that's how it's gonna be all
right so then I just look at the
cross-section so what part is the head
all right I got the head you're way
behind
Carver come on get your okay you're a
[ __ ] together man is that even correct
oh you know um guys what's god that's
good all right it's just a flaw whatever
how are we supposed to pieces together
Oh get to it Carver you still funny oh
okay yeah the trick is just to line up
the cross-sections
did you ever dissect anything in science
lab sold back in it's at the back end I
think that's the back end so that means
this ds2 need to be flipped and that
should be it right yeah codex
initialization C yes Jesus love with
elect let's see what we got caboose
there she is meet Rosetta where's your
face doesn't have a face it's not even a
sheep it's an it wears that as an alien
what what does that mean it means they
used an alien brain to unlock the
secrets of the alien machine it's clever
alright let's see what happens when we
activate it this could get a little
weird fingers crossed
oh no now we've got it all wrong this
isn't the marker homeworld
good
the alien see they found the markers
just like I said it's spreading and
consume them it and pull their bodies
from the sky to from the final stage
oh my god them
the moon is the source of the marker
signal not the machine the Moniz
convergence
the aliens say they built the machine to
freeze the planet to keep the moon from
becoming whole if the machine shuts down
everything thoughts and converges is
resumed not just here but everywhere the
markers are spread and this is is the
key turning it all off thank you for
doing all the heavy lifting no you will
home in on us Marcus and hunter sound
you don't undersell I misunderstood
initially that's true but it's all quite
clear to me now it's not only mankind's
tampering which has hindered our
glorious rebirth this alien machine as
well there if that machine Zdenek know
and now that I have this I'll be able to
turn it off the natives of this planet
chose death over evolution now I'll make
sure humanity doesn't make the same
mistake
we will all of us be made whole oh come
on kill them
okay holy crap um things just went to
[ __ ] and in a handbasket I think I'm
getting out of here cuz holy [ __ ] that
that's sand or whatever it is just just
dissolves everything like instantly it's
crazy what is it
oh no oh crap now function storm
Ellie come on Ellie
Oh go oh come on oh come on hey
that cat is still coming we gotta go now
she's all I got
this was her mission she knew better
than anyone how important it was now
we've got to finish this for her
got it do you got it yeah
then let's go Isaac now oh come on
that's so oh it's socks after all that
they mean I know - Ellie whoa mind
hi I left her
Elly
Isak hey keep it together come on man
don't fall apart on me Dannic is headed
down to that machine we can't let him
shut it down
then we're gonna make sure he never gets
there about that all right
hey hey
it looks like Tanika unlocked access to
all floors what do you go huh
where'd he go I don't know Jesus [ __ ]
okay all right we're gonna split up
you take floor one I'll take floor too
okay all right
what's your day keep your head man I
can't do this without you
okay then that is upsetting in a lot of
those really upsetting it really obsess
about bad
I mean poor Ellie she was a part of the
story well actually I thought about it
we didn't actually see her die so maybe
she's not actually dead that is always
something could be but still I think I
know where Dannic is going hit to the
machine he's got to go underground
there's only one way down to big silo
North here aha my locator oh hello Wow
hahaha I have one of those
how weird your head go ha ha ha
oh hello someone else want to play
edition was that a mid-air collision
holy hell yes
yes I took out his rocket with a grenade
uh Isaac Clarke mad but anyway I'm still
holding hope that I bet there's more
people out there
wait hang on I got a yeah I remember
setting up huge traps like this in Dead
Space 2 ha ha ha [ __ ] that didn't kill
you whoa a stasis grenade that's hardly
fair suck it [ __ ] head oh come on I
thought I was gonna pop hats hey you're
not supposed to be here now oh come on
give it shotgun
I don't know how to take cover by the by
I do not remember how to take cover
know if that's a combat role okay I'll
let them Duke it out for a bit
good Wow hear it all right [ __ ]
you sit down mana fudge ah all right
let's take this nice and easy hey hey oh
yeah I'll come back here oh don't you
want to play anymore I'm right here hi
Hey
oh come on stop running where are you
going where you going buddy
where you going seriously where is it
going come here I'm gonna I'm gonna drop
there we go gotcha with a giant
barricade it's nice if this game has
portable D high walls on chest high
walls we're going the right way yes I am
alright let's go up here still sucks
about Ellie hopefully she'll make a
return later I hope she made it out
there seems like she might it seemed
like the sort of writing device where
they might have kept her alive by some
sheer luck of her going the other way or
something I don't know or maybe they
just didn't want player to see Ellie die
that could also be it oh hello oh is
that thing looking for me I had best lay
low ha ha how do I get around you I'm
not very good at this stealth mechanic
in a game how did you find me
I didn't even what I didn't even whoa
whoa where'd you come from head closest
lots of boxes plenty of stompa bowls
okay so nothing too hard these guys
ain't that woo
oh oh oh boy I just realized this um le
was Isaac's last um link to sanity so
without her her I think he's probably
about to start diving back into the
crazies which I like I love I love crazy
I love crazy Isaac ooh ah what is this
predator he'll yeah oh wait no isn't the
sub beginning of the game and the
prologue isn't this deny CDs I don't
explain maybe I don't know hello I heard
that I'm messed with a shotgun
point-blank
hahaha oh thank you I guess but ha
where'd you come from you snuck up on me
don't do that why is my shotgun not
doing anything anymore
ah seriously
shotgun do some damage please you have a
head Splosion how do I take cover oh
there we go
how we go don't thank you don't want any
how're we doing I got hurt pretty good
there surprisingly the probably cuz the
big like the black ones actually really
hurt me all right
what else we got nothing moving forward
who can't reach Stanek I certainly can
reach Dannic hi Jesus those might
actually hurt me stop it ow
y'all need to stop shooting me right
Jesus why can't I hit these guys oh come
on
Twiggy's office [ __ ] I do not have time
for this thanks for the help rocket men
oh god I'm cornered up at aha Jesus how
many other oh oh you think I got so many
med kits good lord there's more what the
hell is wrong with you I'm like I'm
draining all my med kits
I probably shouldn't use them until I
actually get low on health then suddenly
they decide to throw everything at me
almost as if it's the climactic finale
well then I suppose oh hello
ah hapis gasps yeah I suppose I will
move forward then if the game wishes me
to oh not one of these ahead days oh god
they make my brain hurt alright oh god
what is whoa oh oh
Jebus oh goodness Oh gravy
oh my Grundy Oh
what ah ha ha man stop it
you're in membrane oh god oh oh no no no
no no no yes
chase man I'm not here to use my brain
my brain is infected with marker signals
I can't I can't handle it I just can't
handle it man alright Chapter six oh
well alright then
oh that's Carver whoops
get the elevator we're gonna meet you
down there I'm not an engineer yeah you
don't need to be the engineering expert
that Isaac is you just need to be the
engineering expert that Gordon Freeman
is throw the lever push the button
that's all you need to do graduate from
MIT to scavenge ibattz doing good on
time I can probably get into this a bit
let's see how we doing on supply oh so
many supplies not even funny how many
supplies I have dad go wait where am I
going oh I see Burt jerk oh come on
activate there we go buttons are kind of
sticky whoa this is backwards what I was
doing
leap oh boy
this seems dangerous and yet here I go
like a badass alright let's see if I can
actually make a jump yes
oh that doesn't sound good huh yeah like
vows you [ __ ] off [ __ ]
you are both you're both to go to hell
and you you die I know my supplies they
felt the Hound that's actually went a
lot smoother than the other ones
even with the addition of the monsters
okay jump died do I jump that no I guess
I do not okay I do not jump on that I
need to catch up with Dannic hey don't
think that you're even a little bit of a
problem
haha fall down go boom
alright and we're at the bottom we like
bow stomp on corpse wallah man
hi where'd you come from that was not
even close to my target I'm like the
worst at this stasis business fires dog
miss me hey there's someone behind me
calibrating payload standby transport
will resume momentarily All Hands stand
clear resuming operations haha suck on
that danik you got delayed
I'm just assuming that I'm running slow
down getting yourself killed is not
gonna fix this Norton was right about
one thing this is a one-way trip and if
I'm gonna die on this ice ball I take a
daddy with me yeah that's right Isaac
lark but wait can I not die i dint
rather live hey who use such foul
language on me what the hell oh is stuck
I like stick to the we're not even a bit
of a threat to me why do you care it
looks like I just checkpoints saved
which is good because I'm I'm hitting um
the time limit here whew oh I thought
that was a mine or something
I'm heading about my time limit here so
I am all done for now heavy SCAF frame
so I am all done for now thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotations for our video set I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
Oh
god
ah
Oh